[Music]
in faked a baby news submitted by Ola JK
news Oh a couple is accused of faking a
pregnancy and the baby's death in an
online scam oh my it's just funny [ __ ]
has to be a no no it has to be a girl
fun don't find me scam really gotta be
no but if your baby is there any dead
like there's not too much of a cost that
you need to like we attorney comedy like
yeah a little catchy little coffin with
a cute little suit yeah yeah we need a
plot I wonder what the goal for the
GoFundMe was I had somebody send me F
drugs they're like $60,000 well what
what it was like my groom yeah my
grandma sent a GoFundMe is there for you
I don't know she wants to help like one
of her friends are like a family I
thought it was her GoFundMe yeah it's
like she's putting it on but like this
is too much money but if she's part of a
Nigerian scams I think maybe really your
grandma nah she's good she's I knew what
it was about but I was like I'm not
giving anybody I was like this goal is
to unattainable no it couldn't
yeah it's not always a Nigerian scam oh
my god I didn't know you were so close
to Nigerian trying to make sure they
don't have to meet the goal to keep oh
they don't
I thought they had to meet the club you
could pick what kind of campaign you use
so this story here is around KC and
Joffrey go home Chakri [ __ ] him every
Geoffrey's yeah after that character bad
did you hear that that guy quit acting
yeah people on the street that look at
him go [ __ ] you knows you should forever
act yeah just to get a new role rebrand
himself that's my niece we just had that
dick face he does yes that draco malfoy
face if he was my son I'd get into child
abuse but have you seen his audition
tapes like he transforms into that oh
yeah normal self is this normal and neat
like when you didn't and feels like like
this and it turns into something else I
can't did you know he's that kid in
Batman Begins who's up on the roof
really really who's like Batman's gonna
save us is gonna be Chell anyway so this
couple here they faked having a baby
they faked the whole pregnancy and it
was all to scan their family and friend
Matt Amaro what a pieces yeah which they
weren't influencers and there wasn't
people they didn't know at least they
went after family and friends I hope
that it was people that didn't know I
don't think they're shitty I think their
family's shitty money for exposing it
got money from the developer because you
guys don't really understand a motive
here what is it okay think about it okay
think about it think about it think
about why it's not like you're making it
up I'm not ripping you for the big
reveal
I'm prepping you for the big reveal okay
so the big review is I'm gonna flip your
I'm gonna flip you I'm gonna flip the
script on this ship on your minds okay
no no okay
okay so this family must be really
shitty in order for them to do this
without any guiltiness but it's both of
their families
yeah they both come from really shady
families because if I were to do
something like that I'll be like [ __ ]
them they deserve it
they [ __ ] beat me going oh they did
this and they did that you're great
people that kill their parents and their
parents are pretty decent you think
great grandmas are [ __ ] immune to
[ __ ] up [ __ ] no so the grandpa gave
groceries the great grandma gave $265
friends game with oh that sounds really
they also gave him a beating when there
were seven years old you know I mean
like what about that Oh what if their
parents gave them a lot of pressure to
have a baby and they're always like when
you're gonna have a grandpa and you're
gonna have she's 23 he's 27
they could be from West Virginia though
you know Romania oh so they're like see
Pennsylvania they're like Grandparents
already I was born in Pennsylvania my
aunt has 12 kids
oh are you a part of the Amish crew no
but no no but very close but close next
door next door oh [ __ ] I thought
everybody from Pennsylvania and it would
have stopped when I had 12 know they all
loved to have so many like a big family
and sex yeah all right I feel like
they're from over there like the couple
has more than 20 kids yeah I'm feel
sealed see show Octomom I don't know
about that and then they had drama where
the the son was doing some weird stuff
yeah we talked about where he had like
oh yeah he was on the Ashley Madison
site that's yeah yeah they're really
Christian super religious yeah that's
what a more religious I think the more
ball gags the funnier the funnier it is
when you get caught yeah anyway so what
they did is like a friend of theirs yeah
for every cross I see the ratio nothing
for every cross they have in the house
of the ball game baby shower
Wow dude no [ __ ] baby shower like she
was still pregnant
does she look pregnant um not really
yeah and then they even bought a fake
baby doll so that's a joke take photo
love their newborn and said that he died
like a few hours later after the kid was
born this is their story and so they
were trying to get money go you're not
gonna do it they're gonna try it to get
money to want the funeral for this baby
and so they got about five hundred
something dollars and oh here's the
GoFundMe oh you're gonna [ __ ] your
family over for just five hundred is a
picture of a doll five hundred fifty
bucks how much was the doll two dollars
probably like a hundred and something
for 300 just that but they also has this
egg cream an urn I like the cremated
baby they went all that question can I
ask okay now you can okay so my question
is did the family go to their party
because they'll be so funny if they
didn't invite anybody and I did this all
all over video and they still ask for
money and like you can even [ __ ]
invite me if I'm still gonna give you
groceries and stuff there okay we were
at the baby shower okay
I wonder if anyone knew like that was a
fake belly cuz they'll poke at it but I
can I feel cuz everyone wants to feel
yeah
people look at it they just rub it but
don't they come out of nowhere and run
they have a [ __ ] stethoscope and even
if you're not feeling hard it really is
with the rub do the other way they don't
do the watermelon thing try to shake it
yeah you don't you don't know what I was
like [ __ ] Wren does she like slap my
belly oh I slapped her but didn't it
feel good though no but yeah they even
did an obituary posting in the
newspapers okay this is my favorite [ __ ]
how did they get caught oh because the
friend what was it I don't know just it
felt all because she disappeared she
said that she had to go and on like in
bedrest
and before she had the baby before she
had the baby she went on bed rest and
just completely disappeared from
everyone and then right after this
friend was like this is fake and so she
ended up going to the authorities and
they did an investigation and they
didn't find any records of her having a
baby or the cremated like the funeral
home
stuff there was no records of that and
when they finally went into her home and
they did like a search they found a dead
baby they found that doll and they found
like this urn thing what kind of friend
is that true that's a rockin right would
not do that to my friends if I was lying
to you telling you that I had a baby in
the my baby why it would be pissed
I would be pissed but I would talk to
you yeah because you'll be like to me no
no Jews gonna talk to me like yo yo
50/50 or else I'm gonna [ __ ] burn you
I'm so [ __ ] 250 knowledge I'm so petty
I wouldn't let this go and I'd be like
this was a friendship test [ __ ]
you failed oh that's so good elaborate
ass friendship test you're out one time
there's this girl that I saw working at
Buffalo Wild Wings and there's this girl
and she would say that she's as real as
like the stripper story no this is for
real she said it was fake I don't know
what he thought dude she's got a clarify
that's a different video it's for all
the people honestly she I worked at B
dubs a B dubs and she would tell
everyone this was like near Baltimore
area and Johns Hopkins is right there
and she would tell everybody that she
was like in school to be a doctor and
she was doing her residency at Johns
Hopkins and she would like tell all
these elaborate stories about like what
she saw she's like oh yeah she told me
this thing I never forgot she's like
yeah it's busier when it's raining
because there's more car accidents in
the ER and I was like why I never
thought about that you know what I mean
now everyone just believed her and then
like things started to not add up and my
two friends from B Tubbs they camped out
at her in front of her
Oh her to see like what she did
throughout the day you never went to
Johns Hopkins she was telling everybody
like some was like hey can you pick up
my shift and she was like no I can't I
gotta work at the hospital factory she's
a B dubs regular bro dude we knew
someone that said that he worked for the
government and it was this very secret
branch of the government and like he had
left that already and the way that he
communicated to all the other undercover
whatever secret agent secret agent was
by folding on American flag a certain
way and leaving it at the back of his
car because he's like you know sometimes
he just want to call me up on missions
and stuff but when they see that they
know that like I don't do it anymore and
then so he was saying like he went on
several missions this guy was [ __ ]
weird but we believed him because he was
like pretty knowledgeable and a lot of
different things and like when you meet
someone and you've developed some sort
of rapport you're not questioning their
validity right perfect you're just like
okay cool like I get you and then we
went to shooting range we're like oh man
we can't wait to see this guy shoot an
action yeah yeah like he's a secret
agent
and we see him and he [ __ ] sprint
like hey and the funny thing is we have
we have a guy does art he's he's an army
guy right person yeah I called him out
on that because because our friend from
the army was there he was shooting he's
[ __ ] amazing and I'm like hey isn't
it funny both these guys are from the
military and he's [ __ ] really good
and you shoot like [ __ ] he was yeah I am
a little bit rusty today I'm a little
bit rusty where I look we didn't even
think anything of it because we're just
like we trust people and then I ended up
saying uh he ended up telling his
girlfriend at the time so he was
basically cheating on it and then he
told her that he wouldn't answer her
phone calls or text messages messages
because that particular day he saw that
they they called for his services again
he left what is it you know the night
the horse thing do away that's the
column yeah yeah so then he at that
point he couldn't answer his phone he
had to just kind of go am ia for a
little bit here to go [ __ ] a fat chicken
breakfast mission it looks like 50 first
dates scene where he jumps on the back
of a jet ski he's like just keep going
but this girl used to lie about crazy
stuff too and like she heard lies kept
going and she would live on stuff that
had nothing to do with her fake life I
love surprises
yeah
I thought you were gonna say that she
said she's a doctor this whole time I
think you're gonna say and one day
somebody starts choking right is there a
doctor here and she's like
[Music]
[Music]